labour shadow business secretary
jonathan reynolds is uh here with us how
embarrassed are you that we've only
allowed 50 refugees into this country
very i think
we were receiving
very good intelligence reports weeks
before russia actually invaded people
were aware of that there was the
conversation about that so i can't
understand
the lack of planning on the humanitarian
side that the government just seems to
to have not done it and of course
let's all be clear so we're all i think
incredibly heartened
by their ukrainian resistance but
originally people thought ukraine could
fall within 48 hours so of course the
humanitarian flaws would have been
expected to be even greater than what we
have seen the government need to do an
emergency
visa
emergency protection visa this is this
is not business as usual this is not
normal immigration to the uk they should
have a special regime in place
recognizing that these people coming
from ukraine are not in a traditional
they can get visa application
is true i mean they're not needing visas
to go into poland well i understand that
because of the eu what i would say is
i've seen in the past as a member of
parliament how this country sometimes
deals with people coming to it it hasn't
always been very good there hasn't
always been a good distribution of
people around the uk and the support for
them that they require so i would want
to know how many people are coming to
the uk so we can give them the support
that is required especially children
fleeing a war zone but that doesn't have
to be a bureaucratic system that keeps
people out you could do that in a very
straightforward way that would give
people humanitarian assistance they need
in a way that's not happening at the
moment but i must put it to you that
labour is not doing enough to try to
force the government's hand on this
families are having cluster bombs
dropped on them in europe as we speak
we should be doing more but we should be
doing more as a country and we're doing
what we can in parliament not to make it
a party political issue but to make and
advocate for what needs to happen so
that's why we said that emergency
protection visa should be a crucial part
of that on all of these things we want
to see the government do the right thing
we don't be attacking them just for the
sake of it but where they are failing
obviously it's our duty to point that
out and we will do that what you have
done is let the government get away
quite a long time with this with not
putting the economic crime bill um into
effect i was looking at some uh figures
um from uh a barrister who said as far
back as 2018 laws are in place where
sanctions could have been uh put in
place against these oligarchs already so
why have they not been yeah well you're
absolutely right to say this is the
central argument of the economic crime
bill today the government have agreed
with us on several things but the
crucial question is how long is
reasonable to expect foreign companies
to register the true ownership of
property in the uk the government said
18 months originally they've come down
to six months we're seeing 28 days and
the reason why i think that is
reasonable is exactly what you've just
said david cameron promised this in 2016
the process began in 2018 it should have
been well in force over a year ago so
i'm not just saying really 28 days i'm
saying it's 28 days plus the six years
where this has already been announced
and that's why i want to see this action
taken now it's not just about oligarchs
it's about money launders it's about tax
evasion this black hole of transparency
on this issue has facilitated misery
crime and in many cases people being
able to loot the wealth of their country
and stash it here in the uk that's
what's got to change today and what
about the entities and individuals that
have so far been sanctioned by the
government i'm a bit confused about the
numbers on that well
what we are clearly seeing which is what
everyone is asking why are there people
who have been sanctioned by the u.s been
sanctioned by the eu but haven't been
sanctioned by the uk now part of the
answer to that is another part of the
bill this emergency bill that we're
going to support the government on to
get it through with hopefully the
strength and protections in place i
think some of it is clearly that the
government's previous sanctions regime
which was the act in 2018
hasn't worked it's clearly not working
if there's that differential in numbers
i think some of its capacity i think we
haven't taken this area of of the
capacity the country needs as seriously
as we should have done but hopefully
with the amendments that have been
accepted by the government today this
will improve but be in no doubt we've
got to get this right and we've got to
start improving our performance what
will that look like what will that look
like you know for my viewers at home
what are we actually talking about we've
seen yachts being seized off the coast
of france um by the french government
from oligarchs i mean what's going to
happen to i don't know chelsea football
club program well the government seem
concerned by the potential legal
challenge they might get by sanctioning
people if they haven't got a legal
regime that is robust enough and that is
hugely frustrating because they should
have had one in place to clearly deal
with a situation like that another set
of the discussions around this economic
crime bill today will be about whether
it is reasonable to allow people to
divest of their assets to sell it
whether that's a yacht a football club
or property whilst they are the subject
of investigation these are called
unexplained wealth orders they haven't
been working again very well in the past
we've had a couple have yeah
very few relative to the scale of the
problem of course
the crucial thing about this is it's
quite hard sometimes to verify what
really went on in the form of ussr after
the fall of communism a lot of murky
things went on where people ended up in
charge of entire state industries so
that's really about the burden of proof
being on these people to prove their
wealth is legitimate but there are
things that need to be done to change
the regime to make sure that action can
be taken and you're not just simply
giving people a chance to sell their
assets to probably sell them at a
discount but to take the money and run
they've got to be subject to the right
regime yes this regime should have been
in place before today and that's a huge
frustration you might remember a month
ago lord agnew resigned from the
government citing the fact the
government said they weren't even going
to do an economic crime bill this year
for the next 15 months well clearly
that's had to change very substantially
it's going to happen all stages of of
the bill will go through the house of
commons today
we'll facilitate that we think we can
strengthen it if the government work
further with us and other mps do it
would clearly be better if it had
already been in place